in those early days
um did you suffer from imposter syndrome
like that leaped to being an engineer
was was there
especially when you started uh working
in punch the design
on a team of Engineers was there
insecurity
both yes and no I think I've
um
I always try to flip my flaws into
selling points and for that so getting
that job I
I was like oh you're a team of Engineers
everybody working here is an engineer
your customers are not all Engineers you
need somebody who can be your filter and
tell you when something's going to be
too hard for your customers to
understand so it was more me being like
Oh No it might seem that me not having
skills is a bad thing but actually it's
a great thing I need it I represent the
everyday person I understand deeply yeah
what everybody needs and wants yes that
is me the representation of the of the
average human
um but I mean I I remember that so I
studied physics for a year in college
and then I dropped out and I had this
rule for myself that whenever I did not
understand any something I would ask a
question so I was always raising my hand
in class and it's this room entirely
like Auditorium filled with incredibly
intelligent people who are mortified of
seeming stupid and I think that was
really like and I remember people people
at the end of the year coming up to me
being like thank you so much for all the
questions you asked because whenever
there was something that I was too
scared to ask you always raised your
hand so
I think it is a bit of a skill and I
think that is kind of how I Channel my
imposter syndrome is I'm just like
now let's lay it all out there is you
okay being almost like self-deprecating
just coming off I mean I'm definitely
that I kind of lean into call myself an
idiot I lean into being stupid I think
not all heroes wear capes and the guy
and girl who asks the stupid question
is everybody's hero including the
teachers yeah I think it's it's both
it's a double-edged sword
I started out on the internet kind of I
kind of got the moniker the queen of
shitty robots because I posted a lot of
stuff on slash R shitty robots on Reddit
and people started calling me the queen
of Slash r slash shitty robots and then
the slash art kind of dropped so what
I'm trying to say is I did not come up
with that with myself
um but I did happily adopt it so I
definitely came from a place of like
building things that didn't work and
kind of
yeah everything going wrong every time
like happily failing and I think that
was amazing it was a really powerful
tool for me to like not get my
perfectionism in the way because if I
set out to do something that's great
then I'm never gonna start and I was
like no I just need something that looks
funny
um
but what I've realized
now is there's also a defense mechanism
being self-deprecating is like always
beating people to the punch
it kind of was a survival tactic on the
internet of being like never daring to
set out as an expert and I still do that
like I'm terrified to tell people how to
do something even if I know
um because it kind of opens you up for
being shot down so I think I have I
definitely have a conflicted
relationship with it and now especially
as I'm I'm getting older I am more
skilled than I was before I mean I'm a
CEO of three businesses and I'm like I
don't need to like keep on talking
myself down all the time so yeah I think
it's definitely something that has
served me really really well and that is
still like a
thing that I have in my work life and in
my relationships but I'm also trying to
only
do it when it's beneficial to me and not
when it's harmful yeah I mean but when
you're as successful as you are I feel
like people like it when you're
self-deprecating you don't take yourself
seriously you have that humility
I think it's probably the hardest when
you're starting out yeah because I know
I think it was easier
but nobody takes you seriously right and
when you're starting out when you're
young like you know I just realized that
I played a lot more stupid than I was
and
I think it's also
oh gosh I can't believe I'm the one
bringing this up uh but like being a
woman in a male dominated field
and you're like trying I was just trying
to make myself the least amount
threatening or like really unthreatening
because people are threatened by you in
different ways and it's like you have
such a thin line that you can walk where
you're like okay I need to be just
attractive enough for people to not be
offended by my appearance but just
unattractive enough for people to not
sexualize me I have to be just smart and
witty enough for people to be like oh my
God that's really cool but also shoot
myself down enough for other people not
to be able to do it or be like oh yeah
watch this woman try to thinking that
she knows how to
build Electronics you know so it's like
that's a interesting skill to build
especially when you put yourself out
there on the internet yeah
unfortunately that's the reality of the
internet
and it's a skill you have to kind of
develop that's actually why a lot of
really brilliant people avoid the
internet yeah like there's not many
people like at MIT for example there's
not many
brilliant professors or PhD students and
so on just putting their stuff out there
because
like
um if they what like if they really put
their heart and soul into a thing first
of all that's really hard and nobody
nobody sees it and everyone's like this
is boring so there's so many failure
modes like this is boring or like like
you said you're coming off as too much
of an expert you're not self-deprecating
enough but like there's just so many
failure modes and it's terrifying for
people but I feel like that's a skill
you should learn because
most people like nmit or university and
so on are doing a lot of awesome stuff
yeah and he should show it off but I
feel like
you figured out a really good process of
of showing it off when you fail when you
succeed all of it not taking yourself
too seriously but also revealing through
the humor and the self-deprecation a
kind of Genius a kind of intelligence
and curiosity okay I just want to
snapshot that quote and put it on my
LinkedIn
what is your autobiography oh never
you don't want to say that because like
a year from now oh gosh I don't wanna I
don't want to [__] on autobiographies
yeah no no but even just by saying that
I'm [__] on autobiographies I just
me being interested enough in somebody
to want to read 600 pages about them
talking about themselves it's a no well
well that's exactly the kind of person
that should write one thank you but also
I'm [__] 32 years old what do I have
to write about like I went through
puberty I lost my virginity and here we
are like I don't know it's like such a
three chapters yeah it's a coloring book
chapter seven I learned to tie my own
shoelaces